l'enregistrement a commencé et
continuera jusqu'à la fin
qu'oslo est un repris de justice c'est
aussi un informateur pour le fbi
je veux arrêter vous fait que le général
vous demande un trafic de fentanyl
planifié de l'extérieur pour inonder les
prisons bouclera richard klimek avis si
vous en apporter la preuve
vous serez libre on a un acheteur tu
t'achètes tout ce que tu as qu'avant
[Musique]
des flics si ces mecs le décor était un
homme mort tout s'est tu vas avoir une
chance de s'en sortir
je vais de la donner dans quelques
secondes project
mettez vos mains en évidence
j'enquête sur la mort d'un homme dont
j'étais très proche
on ne peut pas laisser son lieutenant
découvrir qu'un informateur du fbi
étaient présents pendant l'assassinât de
l'un des siens vous voulez voir votre
agence affronter le plus gros
département de police du monde
on aime bien la bagarre à quoi vous
pensez
planté le même famille on s'est engagé
auprès de lui on l'a promis certaines
choses sais-tu retourne en prison en
sortira plus
[Musique]
me faudrait faire
assez duré surprise